what about the time you did the grand
mother of two grand boys I called my
grand prince I'm big Lou and I'm a grand
parent of two big old boy and we're
going to be clean never ever never have
I ever gotten arrested I can safely say
I never have I ever snuck out I was in
high school it was innocent right never
have I ever done disco dancing are gone
to a disco Bart participated in a
protest for kids of the sissies
when I was at UC Santa Barbara all of
the kids went down the bank was being
burnt and I got to yes you know we were
like at 18 19
basically just protesting against the
establishment in the Vietnam War
well my first protest was in high school
and we walked out because our high
school did not have a proper gym or pool
because our school was actually a candy
factory that was converted into a high
school when I got out of college I
protested the fact that there
very few african-american old businesses
in the advertising game in Chicago never
have I ever cut someone out yesterday oh
I'm from the west side of Chicago my
mama taught me how to do that
my mama did not intentionally teach you
how to cuss but I've had some
conversations but I'm not sure I guess
somebody no you wouldn't know if you cut
somebody never have ever shoplifted
[Laughter]
might have taken uh like a apple or
orange or peach or something I'm trying
to remember when I was really young
going to the store I think it caught so
I was lucky but I was eight seven eight
rolled out of watermelon out the corner
stove he took me back to the stove
back to the house and I haven't shot
never have I attended a historical event
been present for a historical event
oh I'm gonna say this historical I
actually saw President Obama before he
was president and when he was speaking
at USC that was historical I'm from
Chicago I was there in the part when he
made that
you know speech when he won the election
he's the only man that my husband allows
me to have other than him
you know just had a crush on celebrity
[Music]
okay if you wanna crush like me in the
legs be okay la oh my first one
bewitched really I used to love be waste
no baby oh baby my wife no to ever or
have our not hitchhike oh no that was
dangerous no you might not ever come
home doing that so no never have I ever
lied about liking someone my child David
I like them all no actually she didn't
really date a whole whole lot and look
and the one that she brought home just
my child's parenting style
oh she cost me yeah no I have judged it
but I have not been judgmental
oh not judgmental look these kids can't
even eat oh yeah I have good mine yeah
oh yeah the whole thing yeah I don't
make any talk about you we don't want
any problems
Oh had a favorite child or grandchild oh
my gosh you have to I'm sticking to this
you love all of your children it's a
[Music]
[Laughter]
black out drunk back out maybe you don't
know what the hell how you even got back
that first time ever got drunk and I
don't know how I wound up in this
basement no how would I look like in
this position but I've never ever done
it again yes because it was I was sick
as a dog it was a learning experience
what about the time you did then I'm not
telling oh I'll tell about this one
never have I ever skinny-dipped I like
being naked too much I think I had a
pool hmm and yeah and I think that there
was somebody that used to like to kind
of peek over so you know you have to try
to be Bobby bit when do you find a peek
of overuse done yes
this is fun he's fun and you know what I
really started out pretty nervous about
playing the game but you made me feel
very comfortable okay - so really is a
fun game right it was really cool yes
and that's it but never have I ever
next week we'll be back with but did you
really
you